welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Ahsoka episode 7 dreams and Madness
which is I think my favorite Breeze to
be uttered on Ahsoka this season by
Balin back in episode six this is a land
of dreams and Madness
children's stories come to life in this
episode from C-3PO shutting up a Droid
hating Senator to thrawn giving the best
ever what to who ahsoka's master was I
got you covered with all the Visual and
symphonic details you might have missed
in translations of all visible orbash
and thank you again so much for
supporting new rockstars and our
analyzes of Ahsoka it's been a lot of
fun to try to figure out what this show
is week to week with you all and as much
as I miss sleeping writing and shooting
these late into the night the part of
the night that's darkest just before the
dawn Isaac is where the magic happens so
to all you Wednesday Wookies thanks for
joining me on this ride okay the opening
lucasfilm bumper comes with this music
from composer Kevin kainer
oh
which the closed captioning calls soft
ethereal music roughly the same
description used for ahsoka's moment
connecting with Sabine through the force
later
see her
happy Halloween from clotho so really at
the beginning of this episode we're
hearing the music of the forced
connection between these two but by
connecting with each other they're
opening themselves up to that frequency
getting hijacked by nefarious trackers
really this episode leaves us with so
many questions about these witches but
this episode really opens on Coruscant
in the era of the new Republic we see a
new republic government building which
is a different building than the prequel
era Senate building on this building's
frontal facade is the symbol of the
corsant Guard which also appears over
the courtroom the course on guard were a
core of Clone shock troopers with red
armor who served as coruscant's military
police force first seen in Revenge of
the Sith but showed up throughout Clone
Wars beneath that hangs a blue Banner
that likely has a much smaller golden
New Republic Crest on it this reminds us
of the new Republic Banner that hung
over the amnesty program building in the
Mandalorian chapter 19. earlier that
episode Dr Pershing spoke at the course
on opera house that we saw in Revenge of
the Sith but there is a larger building
on course not that looks like this one
at least in the nighttime shot of the
city in that episode of the Mandalorian
either way I just find it interesting
that the architecture of this previous
age where there were clones hasn't been
fully paved over yet and the new
Republic is just kind of sufficing it by
draping paltry banners over everything
mission accomplished style but that said
technically the seat of the new republic
government is on chandrilla monmouth's
Homeworld not corsant in this area the
capital rotates among the core worlds so
it seems like they just set up this
hearing in a repurposed police HQ like
Center ziono doesn't want to give her a
huge platform on the main chin drill and
senate floor and kind of just wants to
convict her here in a Star Wars traffic
court so yeah here Harris stands trial
and notice that she wears her headpiece
but not the goggles which just kind of
looks wrong like Ahsoka without her
headband and it just kind of like had
the the weird hairline it's just like
too smooth now I know Hera is not
piloting anything right now but you know
I just kind of like my hair already to
go Amelia Earhart style but you know
like the the first part of Amelia's
flight oh god Hera faces a panel of
Chancellor mon mothma as well as Sim
under Hamato ziono returning from
episode three ziono is father to
kazuta's yomo from the animated Star
Wars resistance show as well as senator
marwood from episode 3. now back then
there was a grand Senator and Senator
Rodrigo joining them but now on this
panel is a certain familiar mon calamari
yeah this is definitely Admiral Akbar
with the same head coloration the same
Admiral badge it's a rap sheet I tried
to force it in there sorry about that
but there's also a Celestine which of
course is the same race as neon now this
ain't Nyan he shows up in the rise of
Skywalker years after this and doesn't
look this old this Celestine has a
handbar mustache and he's my best friend
Among The Observers in the gallery are a
bunch of human New Republic officials
there's an ishi Tib and a white chin man
calamari there's an etherian race and
there seems to be Amon calamari
prosecutor for the state and for the
defense
Chopper and Hera's first officer big
cockheads meanwhile the chains of the
pendant that mon mothma wear to class
per cape look very much like the ones
worn by Caroline Blackiston when she
played the character in Return of the
Jedi now as the panel deliberates the
doors whoosh open and in stress Captain
Carson tiva in a fly fly boy jacket even
that ishi tube in the Montgomery behind
Hera lean over to each other clearly
saying something like get this man into
Poe and Finn's Brotherhood of the
traveling jacket ziono dismisses Hera's
report as a Jedi fairy tale reading Jedi
false Jedi star map star whales distant
galaxies
honestly
are we to believe any of it now Balin
also described these events as children
stories come to life and it just kind of
feels like a meta defense from Dave
baloney on his version of Star Wars that
just because something sounds like a kid
story with magical wolves and witches
doesn't mean it isn't plausible and cool
ziono completely objects to Hera's
mention of Imperial Remnant calling it
sensationalism reminding this of the
kind of people in our world who get
offended on behalf of neo-nazis when you
call neo-nazis out for Dewey Neo-Nazi
things meanwhile Carson Diva will not
stand for this what about the conflict
on Mandalore Gideon was a warlord acting
on his own there's no proof of a greater
conspiracy ah this line confirms the
timeline of the Star Wars series Ahsoka
is definitely set after the events of
the Mandalorian season 3 which ended
with Mom Gideon's base on Mandalore and
Gideon was not acting alone he met with
the pro-imperial shadow Council he was
working on clones of himself and on that
shadow Council was gilad Pelion thrawn's
right-hand man from the Timothy Zone
novels it's someone who actually made a
voice cameo in the rebels finale I'm
actually beginning to think Senator
ziono might have been bought off by this
Council but then a familiar voice
returns hi I'm Steve trippier
I love how mon mothma completes his
sentence Anthony Daniels returns to play
the character at least to voice him
because if you look closely at the
costume I just don't know if that's
Anthony Daniels the guy's getting up
there in age if you take a look at
threepio's neck here it just looks a lot
thicker than usual the head is a bit
tilted back when Anthony Daniels is like
an expert mime actor always has a very
specific way he holds the character and
typically leans his head forward and
pulls his shoulders back but either way
3PO is here on behalf of Senator Leia
Organa and it's just such a nice
workaround since you know Carrie
Fisher's no longer with us we can't
really have Leia appear here in person
unless they were to do some like uh
nightmarish rise to Skywalker VFX that
none of us really need right now just
having 3PO instead works so great
actually if you listen closely when that
guard is giving him Guff you can hear
3bo sane
hey
how rude exactly the same ways he does
to that cloud city protocol Droid and
Empire Strikes Back who swears at him
nice to see a familiar face
profanity naturally is 3PO introduces
himself we do hear a light motif of John
Williams main Star Wars theme and
remember Hera and ripio actually met in
Rebel season 1 episode 3 droids in
distress which Ends by revealing 3PO and
R2D2 we're researching the crew of the
ghosts on behalf of Bale orgata which
would later lead to Hera joining the
Phoenix Squadron so she really has 3PO
to thank for her current position 3PO
and Leia are covering for Hera saying
that Leia ordered the mission to citos
being regrettably unaware that Senator
ziono had held a vote against such a
mission
without her yeah the way 3PO leaves that
pause before without her is so great
he's kind of making this political
charge an implication that ziono rushed
the vote without allowing the great
Center Leia Organa to be present for it
moves like this though are going to
eventually cost Leia a lot of political
capital and leave her with fewer allies
when she's ousted during the events of
the bloodline novel we learned that Leia
is currently leader of the defense
Council which will probably set her up
to form her own militarized faction the
resistance after she leaves now ziono
makes a big mistake he says that they
can't admit evidence from a mere Droid
and Chopper is ready to LEAP across at
Deus batava holds him back stick around
to the outro of this video to see what
Chopper does next yeah we gotta post
credit scene in this video You're Gonna
stick around all the way to the end now
there is a screen on the far side of
this room with orabesh text across the
top of it translates to New Republic and
then on the right Hall of Justice docket
now the scrolling orbash beneath on the
right is kind of hard to make out but I
can see the word case in a few instances
c-a-s-e so it's probably just case
numbers on the socket for that day but
on the left side of the screen our red
and blue cells that might correspond to
the red and blue lines on that star map
grid which could refer to possible legal
jurisdictions where these crimes were
committed and a reminder that the
galactic star map had new boundary lines
drawn by Imperial cartographers during
the age of the Empire that didn't always
align with the way Rebel factions would
organize this is something that was
discussed by the ISB in the show Andor
remember that show where they could just
get a lot of interesting juicy drama out
of a debate over legal jurisdictions
okay moving on to Ahsoka still in
hyperspace with the pergol Ahsoka trains
with both our lightsabers now holding
both reverse like daggers reminders of
Ahsoka in the later seasons of Clone
Wars when she wielded her green
lightsaber and her shorter yellow green
Shoto blade Hayden Christensen returns
as Anakin Skywalker wearing his Clone
Wars era Jedi armor with the crest on
the pauldron and he says in this war you
will face more than just droids
General Grievous massage Ventress even
Count Dooku yeah it seems like since
encountering Anakin in the world Between
Worlds Ahsoka is back to being
comfortable with her old Master seeing
him not as a painful memory to black out
but a source of inspiration and yes this
was a recording made during the Clone
Wars we know who Grievous is and Dooku
is but some of you might not know who
asajj Ventress is shame on you shame
just kidding we make these videos for
everybody so here's suicide of
interested she's an awesome character a
recurring villain in the Clone Wars
series she's a death Marian Warrior who
served as Dooku's acolyte aspiring
Apprentice she actually rejoined her
death of Marion Knight sisters in Clone
Wars season 4. they baptized her into
the coven and this is around the time
when the nice sisters came in a conflict
with Grievous and Dooku and sorry to
disappoint you Assange of interest is
dead now but who knows this show is
obsessed with night sister history she
might come up again maybe she's in one
of those coffins that'd be fun probably
not though now we hear Anakin's
recording say as your master it's my
responsibility to prepare you so
practice these forms often or at least
more than I do so beyond Anakin's
recurring training throughout the Clone
Wars series this recording extra reminds
us of two things Rebels season 2 episode
18 shroud of darkness when Ahsoka
actually listens to a different
recording alongside Ezra
adjustments to the classic form 4
techniques that I think you'll find work
well against droids and other ranged
attackers here and by using two Sabers
during this training session Ahsoka is
essentially doing form four applying the
new lessons that Anakin prescribed after
messing things up in his two-on-one
saber fight with Dooku and attacking the
Clones but specifically Anakin saying
the words as your master it's my
responsibility to prepare you Echoes
tales of the Jedi episode 5 when Anakin
puts Ahsoka through a test Beyond Droid
combat using Rex and Clone Troopers to
try to stun her over and over and over
again this
is about life and death and as your
master I'm responsible for you now
Anakin goes on to say in this episode
you can hold off Rex and the boys you'll
be ready for anything on the battlefield
well
anything with a blaster at least
chillingly this episode of tales of the
Jedi ends with Ahsoka and Rex flashing
forward to the Clone Wars series finale
right before they face other clone
troopers during Order 66 so dramatic so
amazing because Ahsoka will have to put
this Clone Trooper defense to the test
also fun fact young Kane and Jairus then
known as Caleb Doom cameos early on this
episode is a fanboy totally crashing
hard on ahsoka's moves it's a really
good episode you should watch it it's
only like you know 12 minutes or
something now the recording says can we
get separated or something happens
you need to be able to make it on your
own
don't be afraid
just remember what I taught you and
trust your instincts like how right on
the words taught you the framing lines
with the circus blade right against
Anakin's face now while this is a
recording it just feels like Anakin is
talking to her in real time and it's
kind of wonderful I know you can do this
is so good
but it's also kind of sad because it
reminds me of that scene in Minority
Report when Tom Cruise talks to the
recording of his dead son as if it's a
conversation in real time Ahsoka says
Anakin made 20 more of these recordings
and this was his last one he made 20 or
more of these recordings
this is last one
it's a good master
now the music swell after this line
kinda sounds like Yoda's Theme it kind
of feels like she's saying this out loud
to Balin who used her doubt about
Anakin's incomplete tutelage against her
and I hope some of the other 20
recordings were just Anakin bitching
about Obi-Wan or rehearsing what he was
going to say at Padme that day
like sand I like sand or I hate sand I
hate sand I hate sand coarse rough
irritating gets everywhere how do I get
everywhere with her now inside ahsoka's
Locker are a few training remote droids
like the one loot train with on the
Falcon and like the ones Ahsoka wrecked
while she was training at the beginning
that tales of the Jedi episode we see
one yellow one blue and one green here
hu Yang debates with Ahsoka about the
odds the Pergo took of them to the right
galaxy even I think the odds are pretty
good no no in fact that terrible
astronomically terrible yes droids like
this are always acutely aware of the
probabilities the possibility of
successfully navigating an asteroid
field is approximately 3720 to watch
never tell me the odds actually speaking
at that moment an Empire Strikes Back
the T6 having to fly through this
Minefield definitely parallels that
asteroid field after the Hoth escaped
and actually later huiang says we're
going to get pulverized if we stay out
here much longer which is a lot like
what they're saying when they're trying
to get out of the asteroid field now
these mines of the Minefield are called
orbital minds and they actually first
appeared in the poe Dameron annual comic
number one what we see here is an insane
number of them Tie fighters can
supposedly hold six of these at a time
but I don't know how thrawn would have
had this many of them after being
suddenly exiled to paridia I guess the
Chimera just had like a whole bunch of
them I like how the pergol all nope out
of this mess so apparently pretty is not
the end of their Road they can also swim
upstream as well as they can swim
Downstream from the eye of Scion comes
nine of the fighters we saw back in
episode Three Star Wars is officially
called these rp82 fiend Fighters or that
might just be the name of Shin's fighter
in particular but in the past I pointed
out how their design seems to be based
in part on the Clone Wars era belab 22
as well as the real world Mig teen that
was a Soviet fighter used in the Korean
conflict in the early 50s as well as the
P-51 Mustang and the f2f Brewster
Buffalo Ahsoka uses these floating bones
of the pergol in the ring of the planet
its cover from these fiends so whether
the pergola or Alive or Dead they are
just going to be used as cover so I got
a call from my bank recently asking me
whether or not I'd spent 15 Grand in
Vegas and yeah although I guess a
shopping spree in Vegas does sound nice
fraud sure isn't but the good news is
you know that your financial info is
secure just by using PayPal more than
422 million people were affected by data
compromises in the year 2022. every time
you buy something online your financial
information is logged on a new site with
new security protocols it's just too
much to keep track of for any one person
PayPal gets that which is why they work
hand in hand with over 35 million
Merchants worldwide to help protect your
financial data payments and eligible
purchases add in your credit cards to
your PayPal app gives you access to 24 7
fraud monitoring passkey login Security
Financial encryption purchase protection
on eligible purchases and lets you send
money securely there's never a bad time
to rethink how to keep your digital
wallet safe and you can start right now
by using the link in the description to
download the PayPal app today on the
surface of Meridia we get this shot of
the Chimera over the Fortress and all
the statues that we talked about in the
last episode seem to be bent backwards
so that the faces are facing up in
addition to their Silhouettes reflecting
The Columns of malachor in the rebels
season 2 finale I'm still wondering
about the functions of these towers and
again I think it's possible that they're
just kind of like radio beacons that can
blast night sister voices wherever they
need them to go now we have to talk
about how this Fortress was actually
built by the zepho it sounds like zepho
are an ancient race of death mirror
linked force wielders and the game Jedi
Fallen order last week you may remember
I spotted some of that Sith erkatot
runes above the door of the Fortress and
actually Tommy J Wall on Twitter came
through with this translation praise
kujet ruler of all may his Reign last
for all time kujit was the cruel leader
of the zepho and it's actually his tomb
you explore or in the Jedi pollen Order
gain so from this we know the zepho and
the death of Miri have this kind of
parallel ancestry as both of them are
races from another galaxy who immigrated
to the planet of dathmir in our galaxy
after leaving this place but it seems
like some of the death of Mary had to
stay behind there are also some zepho
hieroglyphs from Jedi Fallen order on
the exterior balcony wall behind thrawn
and that one scene in episode six after
he lets the bean take off hieroglyphs
that if we're not mistaken also seem to
appear on the arch of the Coruscant
courtroom behind the Deus so I don't
know maybe the set designers of this
show are just throwing them in
everywhere Morgan ellsbeth hands thrawn
research on Ahsoka from the
inquisitorial database referring to the
Jedi Hunters the inquisitors of which
moroque was one making me wonder how
long he was being night sister puppeted
under that Inquisitor armor how many
people are they puppeting within
different organizations of Star Wars but
we actually know ahsoka's name was
written in orabesh on the inquisitors
list in that 2017 Darth Vader number
seven comic and thrawn realizes a master
was General Anakin Skywalker an
important fact that I'm actually
surprised he didn't already know she
famously served alongside Anakin
Skywalker in a number of Clone Wars
battles as a commander but really in
this moment I think thrawn is putting
together that her master became Darth
Vader however we are getting to know our
adversary and if she's anything like her
master she'll be unpredictable and quite
dangerous and thrawn continues this is
why we must control all variables put
her on a path of her own choosing so
that no matter which direction she takes
we'll always be one step ahead of her
yeah this is the throne we know from
rebels in the Timothy's on novels he
often lets his enemies Escape so that
they can play right into his bigger plan
Ezra and Sabine meanwhile are traveling
with the new team whose homes have
turned into mobile trailers like covered
wagons a toddler no T waves at them and
it looks like this toddler has a knitted
plush doll of a nodie Ezra wears a kind
of scaled chainmail which some have
speculated could be made of Stormtrooper
dog tags but we have to note that
Stormtroopers and Star Wars have never
been known to have dog tags if they were
they'd probably be Imperial Insignia you
know not like real world American GI dog
tags also wearing dog tags of like
dozens of Stormtroopers that he killed
would just be I think a more violent
move than this Jesus era of Ezra seems
to be up for Ezra and Sabine recap the
events of the end of the original
trilogy The Empire was defeated Battle
of Endor
the Emperor died that's what people say
that's what people say huh Sabine
skepticism sounded a bit like our first
step toward this somehow Palpatine
returned poor Oscar Isaac he gets
dragged for that too much you're a great
actor Oscar Isaac they just gave me some
poopy dialogue to say also Ezra
clarifies that Zeb is training recruits
and it's our first mission of Zeb on
this series finally we have one more
episode and we know lucasfilm made a
live-action Zeb for that cameo in the
Mandalorian so if we don't get a reunion
between Zeb and Ezra in this finale
we're gonna Riot Ezra is surprised that
Ahsoka took Sabine on as an apprentice
trained a little before back when I was
first learning I remember he's
referencing sabine's brief training with
a dark saber under Kanan Jairus and the
rebel season 3 episode Trials of the
darksaber one of the best of the rebels
series definitely watch it we see the
great mothers clotho lakesis and
actropod arriving and we see why thrawn
let Ahsoka go so that she could try to
sync with Sabine and that would ping the
four cell phone towers for these night
sisters to triangulate her position it's
interesting to see Morgan joining this
ritual chanting along the Knight sisters
are a coven their sorcery is probably
Amplified by their numbers but these
night sisters immediately respond to
thrawn without hesitating they call him
our Lord so why are the Knight sisters
so loyal to thrawn well as balen and
shin talked about last episode they are
desperate to flee paridia and thrawnship
and the eye of Scion seem to be their
best bet but I do sense that the moment
they'll get what they want from him
they're gonna turn on him they're just
flattering his ego to butter him up
bendu did warn that thrawn would be
defeated with many arms and a cold
Embrace and if that didn't apply to the
pergola it could apply to the zombified
Knight Brothers and night sister is in
those caskets as Ahsoka and huiang wait
notice that the T6 is covered in these
tiny creatures which kind of resemble
Plankton Plankton do break down see
particles in the ocean maybe these are
space Plankton breaking down the bones
of the pergol there is a such thing in
Star Wars known as air shrimp but those
are like on the border of atmospheres
these are just in open space but I like
the idea of seeing these aquatic-esque
creatures because they may actually be
helping Ahsoka mentally return to an
aquatic headspace of the world Between
Worlds because when she channels the
force the sound does drop away as if
she's being plunged into something or in
a kind of sensory deprivation tank
then Asoka looks directly at the camera
and says
see her
[Music]
that thud uncle's eyes opening is just
so scary Ahsoka goes from thinking she's
talking to Sabine her sister figure to
instead locking eyes with a ninth sister
witch that she didn't know was on this
group chat it's kind of like Dorothy
trying to talk to Annie M and the
Crystal Ball but instead it's actually
the Wicked Witch of the West messing
with her always scared the crap out of
me as a kid throw on tells Shen to kill
Sabine and Ezra then take your place in
the coming Empire wow so it seems like
Balin is sensing Shin's interest in the
political power thrawn is promising and
Baylands Divergence from that goal so
does balen know that thrawn is setting
them up as bait does Balin wheelingly
throw Shin under the bus here well not
necessarily I think he is trying to set
up chin to take the path that is best
for her yo ambition
drives you in One Direction
my path lies in another this actually
ties into their namesake the Wolves of
Norse mythology skull and Hattie skull
pursues the Sun the source of light Pati
pursues the moon which is a mere
reflection of the Sun's light skull is
after something deeper than hati so what
is that thing I've speculated Bindu the
mortise Gods the Wellspring priestesses
but in yesterday's video I talked about
den of nerd's theory abiloth watched
yesterday's video for more information
on that maybe he's after that zepho
kujit maybe there were Cottons I love
how we still have no idea but I would
say of the various options the closest
to the Sun really I think our Best Bets
are bendu or the priestesses of the West
Ring of Life or just something
completely undefined yet by the way
crazy detail about Balin spotted by
Twitter user Nira 592 baylin's wrist has
an orbash list of names Luke Leia Han
Chewie R2D2 C3PO and bend if this is
just a Star Wars set designer Easter egg
that Ben would be old Ben Kenobi but if
it is a hit list of some kind hey Ben
solo is around five years old right now
he's not kylo Ren yet he's just little
boy thrawn's night drippers load into
some l-a-t-l-e Patrol gunships thrawn
doesn't send in the Tie fighters why to
avoid using resources he wants to get
Ahsoka on the ground to take up as much
time as possible later when these land
you can see some orabesh on the side of
the ship reading lewd point and then up
on the cylinder the thing that looks
like a vent it reads vent so the no T
Caravan ends up in a chase that kind of
feels a lot like John board's Stagecoach
which really every Western wagon chase
that you see in movies is pulling from
one note he uses a slingshot which was
one of Ezra's favorite weapons to use
back in his pre-lightsaber Dennis Menace
phase and rebel season 1 as her child's
to Circle up the Caravan and they seal
themselves up the way they do in their
shells when they hide when Pioneers
would do this this is actually where the
term circle the wagons comes from as
this would be how pioneers would protect
the vulnerable in their Caravan from
outside Raiders Ahsoka jumps out of the
T6 and rolls up to Balin and here you
can see what a lot of folks have been
chatting about the green Crystal on his
belt buckle which might be his old kyber
Crystal before he replaced it with an
orange one and his old Jedi Hilton and
and one new detail that I just spotted
is that Shin seems to have chunks of
that same green crystal in her Padawan
braid only now visible in the exterior
light so Balin may have given her pieces
of this broken kyber both keeping the
crystal close whereas Ahsoka back on
citas first only use one blade while
fighting Balin now she ignites both of
them confident in her training from
Anakin to use the form 4 style that he
never truly mastered against Dooku and
attacking the Clones because the last
time he used two blades he gave into the
dark side to do it to Dooku this time
Ahsoka has transformed into ahsoka's
white and balen shaming her over her
connection to Vader no longer holds her
back meanwhile Ezra turns down his
lightsaber the force is my Ally and what
an ally because our man uses Force
pushes and even it looks like a possible
Force kick because we totally hear the
force on that kick but it might just be
a non-contact stunt kind of like Luke's
classic Force kick in return the Jedi
yes that's definitely what that was it
just kind of seems like there are a few
obvious non-contact hits in this fight
but duel with Balin is mixed with
interesting flute sounds and listen
closely when Balin shoves her back
yeah it kind of seems like the flute
Peaks out there it's a battle of musical
frequencies and I love it Shin is swipes
at Ezra and singes some of his hair
close the way he Dodges her blows
reminds me of Luke's Force projection
fighting kylo Ren in The Last Jedi
Orchard M way dodging stuff but then
this awesome moment happens
yes Shin's lightsaber blade contracts
reacting to Ezra's use of the force
lightsabers are supposed to channel the
energy of the user so this is basically
Ezra showing his Mastery over the forest
compared to Shin the gunship's approach
and Ezra starts making some classic
Rebels Ezra Clips here but the two of
them get impatient remember balon's
advice to Shin about impatience it
proves true here it gives Shin the upper
hand meanwhile there's another fun
musical Sting with ahsoka's duel with
Balin
yeah these piano chords we actually
heard over baylen's death march in the
opening sequence of the season
Ahsoka says that she doesn't have to
beat Balin and uses huyang's cover fire
to escape and we stay with Balon for a
long take as he's thinking this over
he's further along his path as his wolf
chases the Sun and you all know I was
looking at the background like crazy
looking for any bendu-esque stirring
among these land formations nothing yet
but I will keep looking and I love that
we see thrawn is commanding all these
units on a hexagonal board display like
he's treating all these pieces like he's
playing to jark hollow chess while
dueling chin Sabine uses her van brace
to block a lightsaber hit so yeah that
Vamp race must be best car the night
Troopers surround them one actually has
red cloth coming out of his helmet eye
holes and we hear them all shouting go
go go go go and when they die they do
not burst into green Mist the way morocc
did so I think it's safe to say that
these guys are not zombified death
troopers from Joe schreiber's 2009 book
not corpses being reanimated with night
sister magic but just kind of worn down
Stormtroopers I gotta say they were a
lot scarier when they were just chanting
thrawn's name last episode but I do
think necromancy is still in play with
those muffins thrawn is pleasantly
surprised by this defeat what a rare
sight almost like the Jedi of old Jedi
of old kind of wonder how old thrawn is
referring to because they think what's
most impressive is how little these Jedi
relied on their lightsabers we're
calling the way Yoda initially
confronted Dooku without using his
lightsaber and attack the Clones where
again our man cheered in way has a
guardian of the wills the Jedi of old
thrawn reveals the whole point of this
battle was just too stall his hollow
display shows the Chimera with the
containers loaded in the red orbash text
translates to Cargo load and the number
ticks up from 81 to 83 to 85 why two at
a time do they got those corpses doubled
up head to toe in each of those also
does it really take three days to move
like a hundred coffins when he got a few
hundred night Troopers and these coffins
float or four out of five of these
things coffin flopping
thrawn says time is very much on our
side now and I should keep it that way
time now I assume thrawn is just talking
about being a step ahead of the game but
hey we got one episode left folks we
could see hyperspace time travel as of
yet probably not but um nerd Can Dream
Ahsoka reunites to Sabine and then a big
hug with Ezra followed by I think the
first laugh that we've heard from
Rosario Dawson as Ahsoka foreign
I think I might be going home after all
what is home to Ezra is it just a planet
of lothal or is it just anywhere so long
as he's sharing a bunk with Zeb no clue
how they're gonna get back to our main
Galaxy if all the Pearl have gotten the
out maybe Ezra could activate his
dormant link to these whales combined
with ahsoka's fresher hook that she got
by making eye contact with that purple
back on sea toss or my hope is that they
just pull an ads for a favorite and
disguise himself with some of these dead
Knight trooper armor and reverse coffin
flop into those caskets as they hit you
right on the Chimera in the eye of Scion
and God while they're on the Chimera I
hope they find those lothal ruined
chunks and Ezra finds kanan's lightsaber
among thrawn's collection let me know
how you want this season to end and be
sure to watch new rockstars episode 7
reaction on the break room mod and
Brandon did an amazing job reacting to
this episode and stay tuned for a
special finale predictions video that
Tommy bechtold and I are gonna co-host
here on the main Channel over the
weekend and again we gotta post credit
scene to this video that you don't want
to miss but please support this channel
by grabbing an Ahsoka inspired fulcrum
shirt available at nerdright.shop be
sure to subscribe to the break room for
episodes of WikiLeaks or soak after show
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rockstars Network big thanks to Noah
Chen for helping writing research this
breakdown you can follow me at eavos
following rockstars thanks for watching
and without further Ado late last night
we all wondered exactly how pissed off
Chopper was at Senator ziono and our
amazingly talented editor Drew Coombs
came up with an answer enjoy support
cannot admit evidence of this kind from
a mere Droid
pop
transfer to manual control
[Music]